nolan facing his former team for the
first time since the trade that brought
him to the cardinals not surprising
nolan aronado is downplaying the whole
thing it's a little different but uh you
know at the end of the day it's it's
another series you know a series that
you know we want to win
it's cardinals versus rockies and i
think that's the big picture and uh just
kind of trying to focus on that jack
flaherty good production he's getting
all kinds of run support and this season
is record 5-0 six-game hitting streak
for tapia back to jack and that's it out
and that's going to hurt your hands
right there
and when he gets ahead
inside corner struck him out this is
just a really nice pitch and this is
where he's got a pitch he's got to pitch
in and out and up especially i think for
him
this ball is roped to right over the
head of tommy edmond mcmahon stops at
second and now with two outs the rockies
have a little something going so with
that hit by charlie blackman now third
all time in franchise history in rocky's
history in hits
and the 01 pitch by jack flaherty pitch
number 18 here in the first
left side kept on the infield
and the bases will be loaded they throw
behind and got him where is blackman
going heads up play by both the young
and tommy edmond and blackman runs the
rockies right out of the innings austin
gomber the former cardinal
there's the big curveball strike three
good start for austin gomber got a head
and then he dropped that great hook of
his in there
dylan carlson
good curveball and another strikeout
get the added first base
two outs for paul goldschmidt
and a pop-up to trevor story and gomber
spilly got the absolute start he wanted
eighth place hitter nunez with two outs
and nobody on for the rockies
left field diving catch he came up with
it tyler o'neill
sixth old time and hits fourth in home
runs fourth and runs batted in in
rocky's history the 2-1 pitch
or renato sent it down the right field
line it's well hit slicing near the
corner and it's down a ground rule
double for nolan arnatto at least he's
not facing one of his best friends today
but then he's facing the guy basically
got traded for so
kind of a hit and miss situation i think
i'd rather face the guy they got traded
for harrison bader five hits in his
first 25 plate appearances
and boehner lifts a high fly ball out to
deep left tapia going back at the wall
gone
just over the wall
it's a home run for harrison bader ron
harrison
take it they're giving it to you two
nothing cardinals
we were just talking about that breaking
ball and i said pretty soon he's gonna
start hitting these pitches and that's
exactly what i'm talking about two out
walk to trevor story now ryan mcmahon
runner goes on the 3-2 tommy edmond to
his right quickly to first the stretch
by goldie and the out
two-nothing cardinals bottom of the
third it's flaherty then tommy edmond
and dylan carlson here's a swing and a
high-fly ball hit to deep left field
flaherty has just hit a home run
his first major league home run the
cardinals lead three-nothing in the
third inning
that ball was elevated and he hit it
pretty good pitch here too first career
home run for jack flaherty
they won a curtain call
there's matt adams
the 1-1
round ball slowly hit to the right side
coming on tommy edmond makes the play
one two three go the colorado rockies
tyler o'neill struck at his first time
and that's seven strikeouts i mean his
curveball
has been outstanding
shook to the slider it looked like
and that's in the air to charlie in
right
and it's a one two three fourth inning
three to nothing cardinals as we move to
the fifth in saint louis
that's lifted in the air to right center
[Applause]
here's the left-handed swinger now and
the 3-2 deliveries swinging a ground
ball to the uh outfield and it's uh
streaming by the car in a second making
it throws him out
so two outs and
here is gomber
strikeout number four for flaherty how
about the lack of respect that mike
shield is showing jack flaherty right
now i just went deep now you're making
me bunt
bunts it in the air that's a oh great
catch by nunez that's difficult not only
because he has to lay out it's difficult
because he has to find where it is
initially and then go oh i could
potentially catch this thing watch he's
going around and he has to run back
great
in the 1-1 pitch
hit up the middle base hit
kisner will score
four nothing cardinals
runners at the corners and the heart of
this lineup coming up
and that's hit left side fuentes from
his backside no chance to get
goldschmidt throw is wide and the run
will score that's been watching somebody
at third base but this is one heck of a
play orinato
five nothing cardinals lead this one
comes back to get him five strikeouts
tonight for jack flaherty
this is a great pitch right here from
jack flaherty get a fastball inside
middle in and you guys can't touch that
right there 95 good firm fastball in the
middle half and charlie blackman is up a
four-time all-star for the colorado
rockies
here's a high fly ball right field
waiting for it to come down it's dylan
carlson he makes the catch one out
eleven straight batters have been
retired by jack flaherty one-two pitch
and he struck about
adam's bats with nobody on base two outs
here's a swing and a fly ball left
center field o'neal he's there waiting
and makes the catch 2-3 in the seventh
for flaherty against the colorado
rockies
and from owen two two three and two
and the three-two pitch to joe
[Applause]
connor joe is out 5-3
wow what a quick reaction by nolan
arnotto a platinum and gold glove third
baseman
charlie blackman the crowd rising to
their feet
the one-two
he struck him out
ends it with a strikeout and a shutout
for saint louis hearing game one five
nothing over the rockies